today
i'm announcing that in the exercise of
my good offices
i've asked martin griffiths the
coordinator of our humanitarian work
worldwide
immediately to explore with the parties
involved the possible agreements and
arrangements for a humanitarian
ceasefire in ukraine
since the beginning of the russian
invasion one months ago
the war has led to the senseless loss of
thousands of lives
the displacement of 10 million people
mainly women and children
the systematic destruction of essential
infrastructure
and skyrocketing food and energy prices
worldwide
this must stop
the united nations is doing everything
in its power to support people whose
lives have been overturned by the war
in the past months beyond their support
to refugee hosting countries
our humanitarian agencies and their
partners have reached nearly 900 000
people mainly in eastern ukraine
with food shelter blankets medicine
bottled water and hygiene supplies
there are now more than 1 000 united
nations personnel in the country
working via eight humanitarian hubs in
dinipro
venezia
lev
uzorod
chernevitsi
mukachevo luhansk and donetsk
the old food program and partners
reached 800 000 people in the past
months
and are scaling up to reach 1.2 million
people by mid-april
the world house organization and
partners have reached more than a half
a million people
in the most vulnerable areas with
emergency health
trauma and surgery kits
just today
a convoy of trucks brought food medical
and other relief supplies from wfp
double ho unhcr unicef to kharkiv
to be delivered by our national partners
to thousands of people in hard hit areas
our agencies and partners are procuring
vital supplies and setting up pipelines
for deliveries throughout ukraine in the
coming weeks
but let's be clear
the solution to this humanitarian
tragedy is not humanitarian it is
political
i'm therefore appealing for an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire to allow for
progress in serious political
negotiations
aiming at reaching a peace agreement
based on the principles of the united
nations charter
a cessation of hostilities will allow
essential humanitarian aid to be
delivered and enable civilians to move
around safely
it will save lives prevent suffering and
protect civilians
i hope a ceasefire will also help to
address the global consequences of this
war
which risks compounding the deep hunger
crisis in many developing countries
that already lack fiscal space to invest
in their recovery from the pandemic
and now face soaring food and energy
costs
i strongly appeal to the parties to this
conflict
and to the international community as a
whole
to work with us for peace
in solidarity with the people of ukraine
and across the world